[Music]
best-selling author james rebanks has
been called england's most famous farmer
his latest book pastoral song is a love
story dedicated to the land his family
has farmed for generations it's also the
story of how he's discovering a path to
sustain that land and a way of life that
millions of farmers around the world
know and love
we visited him in the lake district of
england and saw this author and shepherd
in action
[Music]
this pocket of countryside in northwest
england just south of the scottish
border is a wonder to behold
dramatic lakes majestic rolling hills
and timeless land and livestock cared
for by shepherds like james rebanks
literally next week when i go to bring
my sheep down from the mountain i'll be
doing the same work with the same
technology as sheepdog as somebody has
done six times a year every year for at
least a thousand years maybe for four
and a half thousand years come on come
on there's one first one i mean this is
mind blowing it's still mind-blowing to
me even though i grew up with it my
sheep are literally the same flock of
sheep that the viking had
a thousand years ago they're the
daughters of the daughters of the
daughters of the daughters right there's
almost nowhere in the world where the
farming is the same thing
despite that remarkable unbroken chain
rebank says what's often missing from
tourist views and classic depictions of
this land
are stories of the people who've
actually worked it
the farmers and laborers
this is an area that's been written
about endlessly but you said you never
saw
your dad and your grandfather in those
books a lot of that stuff was
a sort of upper middle class english
literary culture
and it occasionally mentioned shepherds
occasionally it often speaks about how
beautiful the landscape is
but in terms of the sort of
working-class shepherding culture and
who these people really were and what
they thought their lives were about i
just thought the whole thing like where
is it i thought oh it isn't there is it
someone like me has to write that story
put it into that put it on the shelf for
those other books so that my people are
in this story
like many farm children rebanks dropped
out of school as a teenager to work the
land in his twenties he went back to
school at oxford but after graduation he
returned
six years ago rebanks released the
shepherd's life modern dispatches from
an ancient landscape
now he's followed that up with pastoral
song a farmer's journey which details
the dramatic changes rebanks has made to
his land and way of life
morning ladies
what is farming today
for me farming right now is
it's about can i produce good nutritious
food to contribute to feed all of us so
that you're fed and i'm fed and our
children are
can i make a living those two things are
vitally important of course but they
were the only two things for 50 or 60
years after the second world war and
what we're now realizing is that there's
a bunch of other things that matter
can i look after my soil properly can i
look after the rivers that flow through
my land or off my land properly can i
create the native habitats that we need
around our land you can no longer be the
guy who says no my job's just to produce
cheap food don't talk to me about soil
that doesn't work anymore we're in big
trouble if we don't connect these things
back up
rebanks has reversed many of the
adjustments made on this land over the
past two generations when industrial
farming took over so my grandfather
30 40 years ago thinks
growing thorn on your land is is sheer
insanity like only somebody that went to
college could be that stupid that
includes unstraightening rivers so they
zig and zag more naturally and
rebuilding hedgerows in the process
providing a sanctuary for the birds and
bees that had slowly been disappearing
we have to put back the native habitats
that we need in these landscapes if we
want there to be lots of birds a lot of
insects and lots of other biodiversity
but those insects and those tiny birds
aren't feeding people
no they're not feeding people but we
need them why because we don't have
pollinators for our crops um because we
don't have the biodiversity so you start
getting
where you have monocultures you start to
have really big problems monocultures
only growing one crop at one time in one
field can lead to a boom in production
but the constant use of chemicals to
combat the inevitable bust that follows
is something rebanks believes must end
you're down to almost no fertilizer we
don't use any artificial fertilizer at
all zero and that's changed the farm how
that's changed the farm because i'm not
buying that stuff so agriculture is full
of people pulling up to farm gates and
trying to sell you things that sound
like a great idea but you have to write
them a check and it's required us to
re-learn how to grow grass really well
using the sunshine and the rain rather
than
fossil fuels
rebank's strong opinions have at times
put him in odds with his ancestors who
he writes about lovingly but also
critically
when i read your first book you kept
talking about your grandfather
and i kept wondering this guy doesn't
like his dad
[Laughter]
that's very perceptive so when i was
when i was 20 years old i was gonna my
first ideas about writing a book was i
was going to write an angry young man
book um what actually happened was i was
nearly 40 by the time i wrote the book
and
that anger had gone like me and my dad
had got through whatever problems we had
in my early 20s
when i when i ultimately wrote finished
that book my dad was dying of cancer and
i loved him very much and i respected
him very much and he'd grown up too we
were two different people 20 years later
and then in the second book i mean he
emerges as
more of a hero
yeah i i think so and then also looking
back i realize now
how horrible i probably was as an 18 or
20 year old
no and it must have been
a complete jackass to be the father of
so
so yeah i think this is all part of
growing up as and i now thank my thank
the stars that i didn't write the angry
young man book about my dad because
because that's not what i i want i guess
it's better to hate your father at first
and then learn to love him versus that's
right when my when my father died six
years ago
uh there was a one of the last
conversations i had with him i'd like
looked him in the eye and i said you and
me okay and he said yeah we're
absolutely right
and
there was no unfinished business
[Music]
there may be no unfinished business
between him and his dad
but work is never finished on the farm
as rebanks ponders what this place will
look like once his stewardship is
complete
do you consider yourself now
a writer or a farmer i've always thought
i was a farmer that writes and then
i think it's changing uh
i can see the day where i might not be
the most important person on this farm
one of my daughters or one of my sons
will will take it on and maybe my
responsibility was to carry it that
little way and then hand it on and
that's great that's really important to
me and it's a lot more important to me
that my my kids think i'm a good man or
i looked after our land properly than
than that i'm some sort of hot shot
author or something
to me being quietly decent and working
hard at the things you care about those
are probably the things i admire in
people you like being a hot shot author
though
a little bit
he really does right who wouldn't
it's great to see him so focused on the
future so government subsidies have long
been a big part of farming both in
europe and here he says those need to
continue but may be adjusted so that
it's funds farms that are a little more
sustainable moving forward also the
consumer he says has a responsibility to
be asking more questions about where
their food comes from anonymous meat not
necessarily a good thing more farmers
need to take on that contagion that
enthusiasm about the original land
thanks jeff well